es posible tener grupos entera en
moléculas cíclicas y existen varios
tipos diferentes de moléculas cíclicas
que pueden tener grupos éter los más
estudiados en este grupo son los epoxy 2
debido a su reactividad aquí tenemos el
epoc sido más simple un nombre para este
sería óxido de etileno ya que esta
molécula está formada por etileno de ahí
es donde se obtienen estos dos carbonos
así
entonces se le puede llamar óxido de
etileno o se le puede dar un nombre
iupac debido a que hay dos carbonos en
el para obtener el nombre iupac
comenzamos por llamarlo
no como el nombre principal y sabemos
que el epp óxido se forma entre el
carbono 1 y 2 así que podemos comenzar a
escribir
x
eta no como el nombre iupac
hagamos otro ejemplo ahora le pondremos
algunos más
más carbonos allí entonces le agregamos
algunos carbonos extra y lo nombraremos
usando la nomenclatura iupac una vez más
encuentra la cadena de carbonos más
larga bien entonces comenzamos contando
cuántos carbonos hay a lo largo de esta
cadena serían 1
4 como esto así que podemos comenzar a
escribir butano como en el nombre
principal así que escribimos
wood
no aquí y después queremos numerar la
cadena de carbono de manera que los
sustituye entes tengan el número más
bajo posible
así que en este caso lo mejor es
comenzar a numerar desde la izquierda
así tenemos uno
4 para darle a los sustituyen t es el
número más bajo posible podemos ver
ahora que el epoxi 2 se forma entre los
carbonos 2 y 3 así que escribimos 2
pop
justo así
y sabemos que también hay un grupo
metilo unido al carbono 2 así que para
completar el nombre solo hay que agregar
aquí por lo que tenemos 23 epoxy 2 metí
butano como nombre iupac
ahora cómo se forman los epoxy 2 ya
hemos visto una manera de hacerlo y en
un vídeo anterior comenzamos con un al
que no
y al al que no le agregamos pero si
ácido
y un proxy ácido se parece mucho a un
ácido carboxílicos excepto que tiene un
oxígeno extra ahí
y en el mecanismo de oxidación de al que
nos habíamos visto que es un mecanismo
concertado en el que uno de estos
oxígenos
se añadía aquí para formar nuestro epoc
sido de este modo así que vean el vídeo
anterior para conocer el mecanismo de
oxidación de al que nos
en este vídeo veremos otro método para
formar epoxy 2 y ese es usando a louis
grinda para hacer un halo y drina
también empezamos con
al que no
y también vimos este mecanismo en un
vídeo anterior se agrega un halógeno y
agua y vamos a agregar bromo
agua
y terminamos añadiendo un grupo
o h y un bromo en el doble enlace y
obtenemos una adición anti de un grupo o
h y un broma
entonces se van a unir en lados opuestos
de la molécula
así
entonces esta molécula se llama 'la o
híbrida y de nuevo vean el vídeo
anterior para conocer el mecanismo de
formación de una letrina
una vez teniendo la halo y drina se
puede utilizar esa halo y drina para
formar una époc sido muy bien entonces
vamos a comenzar tomando esa alegría y
veamos ese mecanismo para saber cómo
formar un epoxi do a partir de ahí
entonces
voy a volver a dibujar la madrina
voy a comenzar poniendo el grupo o h
aquí bien con su par de electrones
disponibles y ahora aquí tengo mi bromo
y voy a dibujar el par de electrones
disponibles del bromo también y por
ahora podemos decir que cualquier cosa
puede estar enlazada aquí veremos
estéreo química en el siguiente vídeo
así que lo que hay que hacer es agregar
una base
algo como hidróxido de sodio funciona
así que vamos a agregar hidróxido de
sodio n
más
h
- entonces el neón hidróxido va a
funcionar como una base entonces un par
de electrones disponibles del oxígeno
van a tomar este protón del grupo
alcohol y entonces estos electrones de
aquí van a pasarse al oxígeno así que
vamos a dibujar el resultado de esta
reacción ácido base
muy bien entonces que resulta de esto
pues bien ahora tenemos nuestro oxígeno
con tres pares de electrones disponibles
alrededor
así lo que le da al oxígeno una carga
negativa completa y seguimos teniendo a
nuestro bromo
aquí
así
y luego también tenemos estos otros
grupos unidos a nuestro carbono entonces
en el siguiente paso en el siguiente
paso necesitamos pensar en otra vez la
polarización en el enlace entre el
carbono y el halógeno
el halógeno es más electro negativo así
que el halógeno va a tomar un poco de
esta densidad electrónica del enlace
entre el carbono y el bromo y por lo
tanto le dará al bromo una carga parcial
negativa bien este carbono va a perder
un poco de densidad electrónica así que
este carbono es realmente parcialmente
positivo
entonces el alcohólico que formamos
cuando el alcohol estaba despertando
tiene una carga negativa y va a
funcionar como un núcleo filo y el
carbón o parcialmente positivo que
quiere electrones va a funcionar como un
electro filo y tendremos un
un ataque núcleo físico por parte de
nuestro ángel al coc sido en el carbón o
parcialmente positivo
y a esto se le llama una síntesis de
williamson intra molecular y si piensas
en ello si estos electrones de aquí van
a atacar a este carbono eso haría que
los electrones de acá se fueran al bromo
así y es una síntesis de williamson
intra molecular en la que el alcohol
sido es el núcleo filo en un mecanismo
de tipo sn dos entonces
si dibujamos el producto ahora este
oxígeno
que estaba enlazado al carbono de la
derecha está también enlazado al carbono
de la izquierda y el bromo se fue ese
era nuestro grupo saliente y entonces
podemos ver que vamos a terminar
formando unep óxido con este mecanismo
bien ahora vamos a resolver un sencillo
problema vamos a volver a formar un
óxido a partir de un al que no y
empezaremos con un ciclo externo
entonces aquí está nuestra molécula de
ciclo
seno y formaremos un poc sido de dos
maneras de acuerdo
entonces en la primera manera vamos a
añadir un proxy ácido
y hay varios que se pueden usar uno de
los más comunes es el ácido pero c's y
acético entonces el ácido pero si
aséptico
es muy similar al ácido acético
excepto que tiene un oxígeno
será aquí así
entonces es aproximación de un al que no
y cuando dibujamos nuestro producto bien
vamos a dibujar nuestro producto para
formar un óxido
voy a dibujar el producto con unos
triángulos aquí entonces hay un oxígeno
que sale relativo a ese plano y si
nombramos nuestro producto bien entonces
el nombre principal sería ciclohexano y
nuestro epoxi dow se formaría entre los
carbonos 1 y 2
entonces la podemos nombrar como 1
por sí
cloud
extraño
así
ahora vamos a vamos vamos a hacer otra
reacción vamos a empezar con ciclo
externo pero esta vez en el primer paso
le agregaremos
pero no
agua
y eso formará nuestra halo híbrida y en
el segundo paso le agregaremos hidróxido
de sodio
que actuara como base y tendremos una
síntesis de williamson intra molecular y
entonces obtendremos
el mismo producto
y entonces obtendremos el mismo producto
12 epoxy ciclohexano
ahora para esta reacción no tenemos que
preocuparnos por la estéreo química
entonces si piensas en agregar el
oxígeno desde el otro lado del anillo no
tenemos por qué no tenemos que
preocuparnos por la estéreo química de
nuestros productos porque si el oxígeno
fuera añadido desde el otro lado del
anillo serían entonces exactamente las
mismas moléculas 12 epoxy ciclohexano
entonces guardaremos la estéreo química
para el siguiente vídeo en el que
podremos enfocarnos en lo que ocurre
cuando se agrega un oxígeno en lados
diferentes de un plano